-So, I was sitting
on this flight,
and everybody that walked on
kept saying to the woman
next to me, "Oh, my gosh.
I'd know that face from anywhere
or even with a mask on.
Look at you.
I know that hair."
And I was like,
"Who the hell is this?"
[ Laughter ]
And, of course,
she had a mask on,
and so I snuck a picture
and sent it to my wife,
and I was like, "Who is this?"
And then, she didn't know.
And then we sent it
to everyone else that was
celebrity-obsessed.
Nobody knows who this person is.
-And you didn't
want to ask the person.
You're not --
-Well, no, halfway through
the flight,
there was a spider on her leg,
and, uh...
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Oh, excuse me.
You have a spider on your leg."
And she said, "Oh, my gosh.
Thank you."
And she brushed it off.
And I was like,
"I don't know that voice."
[ Laughter ]
"Who is this person?"
-All right.
So you brought the photo.
-Yeah.
-And this is the person
that was sitting next to you.
And do we know who this?
-Who is that?
Please, call 1-800...
[ Laughter ]
-Let me see this here.
-And whoever she is,
please don't be upset with me.
-She has red hair.
-And a widow's peak.
-Is it Debra Messing?
-No.
I feel like Deborah and I
would --
[ Laughter ]
Let me look at this.
-Yeah.
I have no clue.
Jenna Fischer?
-It's America's sweetheart.
-What?
No, no, no, it's not.
-No, no.
-No, it's not Jenna Fischer.
-She's very pretty.
Very pretty.
She looks like she's married.
That's a wedding ring.
-Yeah.
-So she's married.
-She carries a yellow bag.
-A yellow bag.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Tig Notaro.
Tig, hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
How -- Can I help you?
Oh, my goodness.
-Oh, that's okay.
I, um -- I was just
headed off to the airport.
Do you mind if I sit down?
-No, please.
No, absolutely, yeah.
Tig Notaro, everybody.
This is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're off to the airport.
-Yeah.
-And you were just here
last night on our show.
-Yeah. And it's also
"America's sweetheart"
Tig Notaro.
-That's right.
I forgot to mention that.
I didn't know.
[ Both laugh ]
I forgot, America's sweetheart.
-Yeah, that's right.
-What's up, buddy?
How can I help you?
-Well, last night,
when I did your show,
I had shown a picture
of an actress --
or, just a celebrity.
I didn't know who it was
sitting next to me on a flight.
-That's correct.
-Do you have the picture still?
-I do, from last night.
-Yeah.
It's right there.
[ Light laughter ]
-This is the photo, yeah.
-Yeah.
-We were trying to guess
who the celebrity was.
-We didn't know who it was.
-No, people were coming up
to her the whole flight
and saying, "I love your work."
-Yeah, they were like,
"Oh, even with a mask,
I know who --"
Do you mind if I take this off?
-No, it looks comfortable,
by the way.
-Do you want to wear it?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
But --
I'll be asleep soon.
But they were like,
"Yeah, even with the mask,
I know who you are
and the hair."
-Yeah.
-And just the whole flight,
I was like,
"Who the hell is this person?"
-Yeah.
-And then you posted it online.
-Well, I guess you also
aired your show.
Yeah.
-Millions of people
watch our show, as well.
-However you get
your "Tonight Show."
-Yeah.
-This was online,
and the Internet did its work.
-Yeah, and they figured it out.
-Figured out who it is.
And it is Rebecca Wisocky.
-Rebecca Wisocky.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-She is on the show...
-Yeah. I -- Yeah.
-She's on the show "Ghosts,"
on CBS.
-Yeah, that's why I came by.
I came by --
Well, I came by on my way
to the airport
to let you know that
and to let everyone know
that she's on "Ghosts,"
on CBS, at 9:00 p.m.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Oh, good. I'm glad.
-On Thursday.
-Thursday nights.
-Yeah, Thursday nights.
-Tune in to CBS on Thursday.
Thanks, Tig.
-Yeah.
-I appreciate this.
-But I have to go.
-Have a safe --
Have a safe flight.
Tig Notaro, everybody.
Thank you for coming by
and clearing that up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate this.
-America's sweetheart.
-America's sweetheart,
Tig Notaro, everybody.
Thanks for checking in on us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my gosh.
-I got it, I got it.
-You all right?
You got it?
-Got it, yeah.
-Thank you.
I got it. Thank you.
Bye.
-Be well, be well.
Tig Notaro.
[ Laughs ]